we got robbed
yeah the bishops are now really the
mortgage affair with government come at
me try and fart on me come on you are
becoming quite proficient at this let's
hope it works on the big one
and those are our nominees for best xbox
360 game on gamespot game of the awards
2014 and let's start with a new one
let's start with the microsoft exclusive
and fall i can boy ya gain the k-map
seems like ages ago now about march back
in q1 it was a game that people were
sort of craving for months and months
and that didn't disappoint no absolutely
not i mean i was really looking forward
to it as a big competitive shooter fan
and yeah it got that parkour system that
wall running system it just to me it
felt so fresh and in a you know any any
very populated competitive multiplayer
landscape to be able to not only have
your player mobility fundamentally
altered by being able to wall run by
being able to double jump and by being
encouraged to string all these things
together and you know you have to do
that unless you want to be a sitting
duck to have that which would have been
like an entirely great game on its own
yeah but you also have titans you also
called us in and they're all on the same
battlefield and I think the achievement
and balancing those things in creating
spaces where both pilots and Titans can
feel like they're powerful on the
battlefield and it's just get makes each
match feel so so cool and then one of my
favorite things the evacuation at the
end of the match like the matches
decided you know if you wonder you lost
but there's still that rush to get to
the dropship there's still that last
hoorah that really puts an exclamation
point on the end of a competitive
multiplayer match in such a clever way I
wouldn't be surprised if that also makes
the list of things we see imitated in
the future absolutely it was one of
those games like he said a few and far
between do you get first-person
competitive game that really actually
makes you think differently in the bed
the way you approach combat and so yeah
for me as well titanfall was a fantastic
addition to the world of first-person
competitive game but pretty interesting
that it was one of the only sort of
exclusives that you know we've talked
about so far I mean a lot of the stuff
that we are honoring with our nominees
as far is multi-platform
was a huge year for multi-platform
completely and the next four games are
going to talk about of all been
mentioned already in our nominees today
first of all let's talk about dog shows
to ya go variants on a previous gen
console as well yeah totally I mean a
lot of people only get to this point
yeah well we'll get more and hopefully
that means that that lighting model that
people craved will appear that we didn't
see in the first one but but even even
so I still think dark souls 2 is really
great I think it's hard to beat what I
consider to be the possibly the best
game of its of its time which is dark
souls but I think they got they got real
close and it's it's just a fantastic
game I love the way it feels the heft
and just enough little tweaks here and
there in a brand-new world to make seem
really fresh I'm the controller stuff
works right off the bat on this one as
well yeah totally yeah totally
everything just feels right but just the
little things were there to make it feel
different unique so it could stand on
its own rather than have to be you know
just oh it's just it's just a sequel
it's just another Dark Souls well
actually no it has a significant enough
feel you know difference to it that it
really does you know stand on its own as
a fantastic game on the other end of the
RPG as scale we're going back to South
Park for the stick of truth Alexa yeah I
mean I just keep going back to it's like
it's a good RPG we have had so few good
RPGs obviously dragging decide which I
guess we'll get back to but there's been
so so few very well done Western ones
and i think this made a very great use
of a kind of silly property and turned
it into like a serious you know game
with a lot of strategy definitely
serious [ __ ] talkin to a poo yeah well
no they did a really good job fitting it
with into like fitting the South Park
universe into the RPG frame yeah one of
the the sort of debates we had
downstairs was if you weren't a South
Park fun could you enjoy this game
because the combat stuff is pretty light
and comparison to a lot of order and
what role class role-playing games Chris
what did you think about it in terms of
what I think the most telling thing for
me was that this is a game that people
would in the office would go home they
would play and they come back the next
morning all talking about in all having
their
for an anecdote about like this
hilarious scene that hilarious scene
they try to find a gameplay clip of it
to show off or they'd be just like
re-enacting it in the office I think
that that passion for just like that
kind of humor than getting that kind of
response to you like you're it's still
filling you with glee the morning after
is just it's really special fantastic
game and then going back to another game
we've heard a bunch of bed today mailed
your solid ground zeroes my favorite one
of my favorite games on playstation 4
and there were some thoughts and
concerns in our ad debate downstairs
about the draw distance issues on the
previous gen consoles but that didn't
stop it from getting nominated on both
playstation 3 and the xbox 360 and Game
of the Year awards still fantastic a
game like everything that's essentially
in the the current gen version is in
this one as well and it's great to see
this you know snake kind of made a home
on PlayStation for so long so it's
interesting always to see him pop up on
the xbox 360 yeah he was all over the
place man crazy right our last nominee
for the xbox 360 when we've talked about
a bunch already but let's talk about it
again dragon age inquisition hey Kevin
you big fire this bad boy I I do love
dragon age and I think it's worth
pointing out to that one of my favorite
things about Dragon Age Inquisition is
how well it takes sort of the personal
storytelling that you yourself craft in
a large world that you explore and
combines it with that more traditional
Bioware storytelling where you follow
conversation paths and make a linear
story of your own but then you're also
making the adventure story of your own
and this is the first time I think any
games really gotten good at combining
both of those things without making one
or the other feel like it got the short
end of the stick and I think that's
really impressive excellence well those
are our five nominees for best xbox 360
game on this gamespot's 2014 game of the
year awards make sure you check back on
December 16ch we'll be announcing the
winners of this and of course the xbox
one winner as well